there's a job out there in the ether  there's a job out there there's a TV  show that's on right now and I want to  be on that TV show what is it I'm not  gonna say what do you toys anybody just  sit there watching the druggies are you  watching a show so I would do that you  would never expect I would do and the  joke form of this is what I say to my is  it a comedy or a drama it's a i'll be  hosting something the price is right I  can see you hosting it there try it out  this wheel of fortune come on the truth  let me hear you say Debbie Swanson  Peoria come on down your blood Debbie  how are you what i'ma do I'm gonna  Pamela what's the show k double town  what's the showcase